je vous le dise en titre se faire
vacciner contre le comique 19 pourrait
être moins difficile dans les prochaines
semaines le gouvernement veut accélérer
avec l'ouverture de centres de
vaccination éphémère à tour plus de 500
personnes ont ainsi pu être vaccinés en
un week-end à l'hôpital bretonneau un
opération une opération coup-de-poing
possible grâce à l'arrivée de nouvelles
doses du vaccin
astrazeneca pour élire un homme frédéric
à 79 ans il vient de mon depuis quelques
jours il était sur listes d'attentes
pour recevoir le vaccin dans un centre
de joué-les-tours
finalement la donne a changé sa première
dose il la reçoit en plein week end au
chu de tours et hier soir coup de
téléphone de l'hôpital qui me convoquer
ici j'étais un peu étonné climat à mener
donc bon mais je roulais à accepter sauf
qu'on a changé de l'acsa parce que là
c'est astrazeneca est normalement cédée
à 10h ce centre éphémère de vaccination
a poussé comme un champignon
les patients ont été appelés en partie
par les pompiers d'indre-et-loire 350
appels ont été passés en 24 heures car
le mot d'ordre ce week end c'est
l'accélération
c'est une opération qui a je crois a été
qualifiée de blitzkrieg effectivement
danse est une extension du centre de
vaccination qui existe dans la semaine
pour effectivement passer le maximum de
deux doses dont on dispose actuellement
et là on a cinq cent soixante deux
disponibles et on a
de 350 rendez vous auquel on va rajouter
des gens à qui on a demandé de se
présenter spontanément c'est à dire les
sapeurs-pompiers les professionnels de
santé voir le public cible de cette
opération c'est à dire soit les
personnes de plus de 75 ans soit les
personnes de plus de 50 ans atteinte de
comorbidité recevoir une dose du vaccin
astrazeneca au lieu du kaiser certaines
personnes y étaient réticentes
ce week end la préfète voulait rappeler
l'efficacité de cette injection
il faut rappeler que le vaccin
astrazeneca sur lequel on manquait de
données scientifiques
aujourd'hui on a des études portant sur
des millions d'anglais qui ont été
vaccinés qui montre qu'il est d'une très
grande efficacité au moins égal à celui
de 13h et qu'il peut être administré à
toutes les catégories et notamment les
personnes âgées les études qui ont été
diffusés en début de semaine montre que
sur ces millions de personnes ça donne
un taux de chute des hospitalisations
pour qu'ovide de 100% en indre-et-loire
plus de trente trois mille personnes ont
été vaccinées dont la moitié ayant reçu
la deuxième dose